Taxi, miss?
Cheapest rates in Glen Cove.
Well, hello! How are you?
Well, I'm fine. How are you?
And I might add, who are you?
Who am I?
Am I supposed to know?
Come to think of it, no, you're not supposed to know.
Are you stranded?
My father was supposed to pick me up but something must've happened.
Whoever your father is and whatever happened, I'll be eternally grateful.
That is if I can give you a lift.
You certainly can. You can drive me home.
Good! I'll get your bags.
Where do you live?
Dosoris Lane.
Dosoris Lane?
Say, that's where I live.
Really?
Sure. We must be neighbors.
And if there's one thing I believe in, it's "love thy neighbor".
Oh! So do I.
Come on, David.
David? Is his name David?
Yes, it is.
That's funny.
My name's David too.
That is funny, isn't it?